[Musica]
[Applauso]
wow
e oggi vorrei partire con voi per un
viaggio
il viaggio enogastronomico ognuno di noi
decide di partire per un viaggio per per
tanti motivi per un desiderio per motivi
totalmente differenti dietro ogni
viaggio che organizziamo ci sono
obiettivi emozioni si anche aspettative
io di solito viaggio per per lavoro ma
anche per per il sapore della scoperta e
per mangiare io faccio il giornalista da
un viaggio in cerca di racconti
gastronomici di tradizioni di tavole di
cuochi ma anche per mangiare può
sembrare banale ma anche così
durante i viaggi io mangio la qualunque
non me ne vogliano i vegani però insomma
cerco di provare il più possibile quello
che le comunità mimì offrono quindi
dalle scimmie le tartarughe nella
mazzone peruviana alle balene in
giappone dagli squali in islanda ai
cuori di renna in lapponia da coconut
club che sono i granchi più grandi del
mondo nelle isole cook ai furbetti
pipistrelli che si cibano di frutta e
quindi la cui carta e dolcissima in
mauritius e lo faccio per conoscere le
genti che mi ospitano nelle proprie
comunità attraverso le loro tradizioni
gastronomiche
il giornalista michael pollan nel suo
dilemma dell'onnivoro diceva che noi
siamo ciò che mangiamo e io aggiungo che
noi siamo che il risultato delle
migliaia di culture sparsi per il mondo
per il mondo in cui possiamo
riconoscerci nella quotidianità come vi
dicevo io viaggio in cerca di racconti
gastronomici in cerca in attorno alle
tavole di tutto il mondo però prima di
essere un giornalista gastronomico sono
un gastronomo e trovo che lo si possa
essere fino in fondo solo se si conosce
l'origine di quel che mangiamo il suo
aspetto più primordiale il suo ruolo
nelle diverse culture
il concetto di il concetto di viaggiare
per scoprire anche
culture gastronomiche non totalmente
lontane dalle nostre uno dei motivi che
che spinge le persone verso luoghi
lontani voi per per per fissare come
dire il contatto con chi incontrate che
cosa fate
beh io uso l'ho fatto
non voglio dire che annusi chiunque
ancor prima di stringergli la mano però
è una cosa è una cosa a cui tengo molto
perché mi fa capire tutto e il primo
segnale che mi dice dove mi trovo
e che poi serve a scalfire i ricordi
nella memoria dunque non guardate ho
toccate annusate perché ne siamo animali
lo sappiamo ma ogni tanto ce ne
dimentichiamo venti giorni fa per
esempio ero in australia nel northern
territory tra le cittadine di uluru eli
springs e darwin attorno a me c'era solo
deserto ho passato quelle ore tra tra
gli aborigeni come in un tempo sospeso e
loro mi raccontavano trawick di club e
l'altro sono sono dei vermoni bianchi il
loro alimento tipico che qui tutto ruota
intorno alla vita animale loro da sempre
vivono nel bus che lo spazio immenso e
sconfinato in cui la natura comanda e
che questa è la loro casa il loro
mercato a cielo aperto e qui fanno fanno
la spesa sanno cosa mangiare e cosa
raccogliere e io ho cercato di adattarmi
il più possibile alla loro vita e quindi
abbiamo abbiamo cacciato canguri con il
boomerang di cui vi risparmiano foto
abbiamo cercato le formiche le colonie
di formiche negli alberi le famose green
hunt formiche dal sedere verde cariche
di acido formico che
che loro utilizzano per condire le loro
pietanze perché non hanno non hanno
altro
in questo modo sbattendo con le mani
come dire le sto non possono utilizzarle
e addirittura adesso sono anche
diventati ingrediente di un gene
australiana ma questa è un'altra storia
la signora che vedete in foto e pezzi
l'aborigeno a pezzi e lei mi raccontava
che per esempio oggi i vermi di cui vi
parlavo continua a mangiarli marro
stendo lì sotto le ceneri però la nonna
li mangiava crudi per cui per
avvicinarmi il più possibile alla natura
io ho deciso di mangiarne un paio vivi
quindi ancor più che crudi e ce ne
sarebbero ancora tante da raccontare
tutti i contatti olfattivi con con la
madre natura selvaggia che ti fanno
sentire ed emozionato in realtà non sono
solo contatti olfattivi perché vi
assicuro che che il delek così come si
chiama in lingue aborigene un suo sapore
benetto sa di uovo rachide terra ebbene
lo stesso è accaduto cenando con uno dei
fedeli che ha fatto la rivoluzione con
fidel castro o con i rossi robaina uno
dei più prestigiosi coltivatori di
tabacco a cuba o con i maestri delle
antiche cerimonie del tè in giappone con
i produttori di caffè in colombia
bevendo un clandestino tra le colline di
sciamarelli mauritius o mangiando i
feedback di cui vi dicevo prima che
ancora tradizionalmente vengono
preparati dalle nonne mauriziane dopo
essere andato a caccia con i nipoti di
notte nella foresta rischiando di
beccarmi anche una pallottola e lo
stesso è accaduto in islanda cibando mi
del paf in questa simpatica e colorata
pulcinella di mare oppure nelle
filippine questo è il valut un uovo d
anatra fecondato con suo interno un
embrione quasi totalmente formato e
ancora nella mazzoni a peruviana con i
coccodrilli o con il cui
palo che è un porcellino d'india tipico
della cucina delle ande peruviane e
ancora il pace il paese uno dei dei
pesci d'acqua dolce più grandi del mondo
pescato sempre nella mazzone peruviana e
in brasile in argentina a capo horn
potrei continuare a lungo ma il tempo
non ci assiste la caducità del tempo
nemico imbattibile è stato oggetto della
mia tesi di maturità classica e già
allora questo scorrere inesorabile del
tempo mi toglieva mi toglieva il sonno
ma con il viaggio almeno in parte sono
riuscito a rallentarlo
come vi dicevo che ognuno viaggia per
motivi per motivi diversi e e il viaggio
ci permette di fare tutto questo sedere
alla tavola di una delle di una delle
povere famiglie cubane non può che
arricchire inevitabilmente la nostra
esistenza e vi assicuro che queste
famiglie sono molto più ricche di noi
per tanti motivi ho vissuto nel
quartiere più povero e popoloso
dell'avana santo suarez per qualche mese
non c'era giorno in cui non non uno spit
assimo qualcuno non condividessimo un
pasto con qualcuno che ne avesse bisogno
ebbene tutte queste cose non possono che
arricchire la nostra esistenza come
tornare agli albori della della natura
cibando c della sua anima più forte
in realtà però non è necessario andare
per forza dall'altra parte del mondo per
esempio in 2d aereo arriverete a
copenaghen nella capitale danese
e qui incontrerete un cuoco ormai
insomma famosissimo che renè redzepi di
uno dei ristoranti più conosciuti e più
famosi del mondo che è il nome di
copenaghen e lui vi darà vi darà
quest'opportunità cucinando di la natura
con una proposta è una cultura
gastronomica che ha creato lui da zero
perché copenaghen nella danimarca tutta
non l'aveva come l'ha fatto l'ha fatto
rifacendosi agli avi e quindi vi servirà
licheni muschi formiche anche qui
formica e con loro acido formico perché
lui non ai nostri limoni e quindi ha
dovuto adattarsi e quindi farà vi darà
questa possibilità e avrete modo di
riavvicinarmi alla natura rimanendo
seduti a tavola e vi dimostrerà anche
come ha fatto a trasformare copenaghen
da deserto qual'era ad una delle
capitali mondiali del gusto
ormai è una e una meta imperdibile per
qualunque appassionato di cibo perché
dopo di lui hanno iniziato tutti i suoi
seguaci e oggi è veramente una una città
pazzesca dal punto di vista gastronomico
e ancora di più in un'ora di macchina
arrivata in montagna qui in abruzzo e
potrete potete entrare in uno dei dieci
ristoranti con tre stelle michelin
d'italia il reale di niko romito lui non
vi servirà animali strani o formiche ma
nessuno come lui fino ad oggi è riuscito
ad impiantare il territorio servendovi
una cucina tanto essenziale quanto
altissima garantendovi assolutamente un
viaggio sensoriale rimanendo seduti a
tavola se poi avete modo di fare qualche
chilometro in più all'ora e a lima che
dovete andare diventata anche lei
un'altra delle capitali mondiali del
gusto nonché capitale peruviana e qui
con tre re incontrerete un poco
lungimirante saggio che è virgilio
martinez del ristorante central
ecco lui vi darà quest'opportunità
cucinando v
la foresta amazzonica lo farà tramite un
menù di una dozzina di piatti che cambia
ogni sei mesi
e lui è in grado attraverso le
differenti altitudini di un perù
pazzesco di raccontarvi la sua
biodiversità e per intenderci parliamo
di un paese che conta 4.585 diverse
varietà di patata giusto per darvi
un'idea di quale biodiversità parliamo
insomma io
credo di aver capito come come come si
fa a fermare il tempo si io conosco il
modo primo cercate di beccare più fusi
orari possibile così quantomeno da
rallentarlo secondo mangiate con le
persone
terzo cucinate l'un l'altra fate anche
l'amore ma dopo cucinate l'un l'altra se
riuscirete a cogliere la felicità dello
stare a tavola con qualcuno soprattutto
se il più lontano possibile dai gusti
acquisiti abituati
allora riuscirete a fermarlo ea
catapultarvi indietro perdendo nella
cognizione questo è il potere che la
cucina
ve lo assicuro perchè l'ho provato sulla
mia pelle adesso posso voglio lasciarvi
con un messaggio non mio ma di un
signore parecchio povero di nome
francesco siamo nel 1255 diceva così
cominciate col fare ciò che è necessario
poi ciò che è possibile piccolo sforzo
in più e all'improvviso vi sorprenderete
a fare l'impossibile
ecco questo trovo che sia il giusto
principio affinché l'essere umano possa
arrivare dove desidera ci vediamo in
giro per il mondo
[Applauso]